[Music]
hey what's up i'm hans kim i'm from the
podcast kill tony and i make out with a
lot of strippers
that he does i'm bob flacco i am the
singer and guitar player one of them for
another hour
and uh we play the after party at kotovi
i'm connor stevens i play country music
i have my own band but i also hang out
with these guys because these guys are
my best friends and i go on stage
sometimes with another boy you look like
a cat
rhino yeah um
i'm really glad to be here no because i
even myself i know i show them i'm just
a surprise guest or whatever i'm happy
that we have hans here because i do got
some questions for you
who's your favorite stripper to kiss off
top
can we name them stormy is up there
because i kissed her three times now
stormy is they're all great
personally my favorite to look at is uh
that jenna girl right now that's the one
with the right girl that kissed me with
the lip the teeth
i don't know
she's not a good kid oh jenna the
jessica rabbit one they ready yeah
what are you talking about
oh yeah she's great yeah
but she's like she's so like
buck tooth and
in a good way i like a southern belle
kind of way exactly you know what i'm
saying a little bit a little southern
woman real southern child yeah
thank you man
yeah but uh nah it's been fun man it's
been a blast the coolest part is so the
first time we got to attend and play
the after party ever kill tony was the
time you got named regular here in
austin like literally
our first kill tony show was his first
alex jones or was the time he got asked
to be a regular yeah
yeah
so hans you better even remember that
night
i got blasted as [ __ ] how long you've
been in town for like a few months
march 20th is when i rolled into town
and the stealth of night in my spearman
yes
did you expect all this to happen or
unfold the way it did nope
well it's like a pipe dream but uh it's
like you can't rely on it
but uh yeah my wildest dreams have come
true and
you know i'm still in it yeah man i mean
hey you're talented dog you know what
i'm saying whenever you're good at what
you do good things happen but you got to
put the work in i know you've been
grinding give us a little bit about that
dog tell us about where you came from
like where were you at before you made a
toss i came from the streets of seattle
dang i did mike's there five years in my
little
car
that i uh had for my family my family
but this is like back in the day it was
actually a nice new car for back then
and it just hit all the mics because i
have a car you know and then i could go
around and i could do all the mics
i did like five mics tonight
in seattle bro
uh yeah
five years what got you into comedy were
you uh were you like the bully in school
or were you kind of like picked on
growing up that was like the nerd i was
like hey
i was like this
oh [ __ ] that's how you work
[Laughter]
what got you into doing this though was
it just like a spur of the moment like i
know i'm funny i'm just gonna go out and
do it nature capitalism
are
is
and uh disgruntled
and then we uh look for uh means of
owning our own
uh methods of capital uh you know which
is your name it's your brand yeah you're
[ __ ] selling my personality yeah you
are tipping myself out
yeah i mean do it dog hey bro pave
yourself out as much as you [ __ ]
can't do whenever you learn how to do
that that's where you start raking in
the [ __ ] daddy dollars
yeah that's important for survival but i
live in a van so i don't really
require much from you are you still
[ __ ] are you still really living in
the vanity
i have a power outlet and our other
buddies taking a power outlet from riley
gilmore there you go we get to mention
the shout outs out to raleigh gilmour
that's a funny ass but if i was in the
woods
i would have so many more advantages in
the van
like what you don't even know i have a
hatchet do you have a hatchet
i don't have one in my personal car but
my work truck i do have my oh and your
work truck you said exactly like i said
how many people have ownership of this
work truck because for me it's just my
band parked out here and i can just
that's your laboratory dude
do you remember that video that kai
video they do with the hatchet
smash
the ass smash
dude you got to watch that this guy
looks like if me and you had a kid or
something
straight up hey no but on that [ __ ]
note dude hans coming up with a [ __ ]
true vaccine in that van let me tell you
about the vaccine i got it all yeah i
got the modern i'll give you a waxy look
for that vaccine
i got the uh
oh i mixed it yeah
after my five year
trek through the seattle mic scene i
settled upon the city of new york
the fair big apple oh you went to the
bay i made it
yeah and then i supplied my cross for
three years in the trenches with the
sewer dogs and the subway racks yeah you
did that's a great description you're a
good writer
you are
you are no i i might bro about anybody
anybody who's good at [ __ ] making
words makes sense there's people out
here grinding out there every night that
we see every [ __ ] night and to me
that's that whether they've
acknowledged it or not it's just
happening you know what i'm saying like
so i don't think it's become that yet
but i think inevitably it kind of is
that we all came here victor tran it's
coming
why are you screenshotting my messages
bro
no
hey what's up
you're very funny he has a funny joke
should i say it
yeah
say it
he has a funny joke where he's like tony
hinchcliffe if you call me [ __ ]
i'm gonna have to meet you in the
parking lot but if joe rogan you call me
a chick
i guess i'm a chick then
pins are supposed to be smarter than
this
above the liberal nonsense but we're
playing right like
conservatives in america are so dumb
that you just have to be like one level
smarter than them but then in asia
there's like levels above like just
being smarter than your opponent there's
like you know because we're all the same
size
so
it doesn't [ __ ] matter you're a big
guy
i mean i had to be my muscles were like
triggered by being in america i was like
[ __ ] are you kind of jerking why are
these people talking about my penis hans
cameron
[ __ ] killer though
dude i've heard good things about your
peen too dawg you know what i'm saying
we do run with a circle right here you
know what i'm saying all i hear is
people to say good things about you man
so you know what means keep making good
choices keep being funny when does the
bathroom break happen yeah
oh it's online
you want to see it yeah
you probably clip a bit in there ty
where was it i was like renee's
homeworker she's an ugly [ __ ] trying to
try and get late she's going to be sad a
lot of the movies she's going to scrunch
your face
i don't know i don't know what the point
was uh
asians seeing me drive and then i have
to like drive really perfectly into a
parking spot
or else like people are gonna judge me
like oh he's asian
it's like oh this pressure i feel every
day being asian
yeah damn dude
where did you do that at
dry time in capitol hill okay okay
all right so uh out of the three guys
what's the craziest homeless person
experience you've uh encountered while
being on the road
i'll be on the road
or just in general yeah go connor
connor's got some wild ones yeah well
i'm from austin so like i would like
like shout outs to wherever the [ __ ]
tony's at yeah i was born in dallas but
i've been in austin for like 17 years or
so so i'm i'm oh yeah so i'm from los
angeles yeah i'm from australia yeah
yeah and so
yeah you said you kind of get it yeah
yeah i'm in the water oh so what
happened with the homies oh man tony
well well me and my boys just like i
didn't really have a whole lot of
friends so i was just like doing drugs
in high school and then i got kicked out
of westlake uh shout outs to the [ __ ]
dog carter
i [ __ ] just started like would go i
would go down to the [ __ ] vape shop
area and there'd be a bunch of homeless
people and we'd just got to smoke weed
at [ __ ] barton springs oh you were
hanging out yeah bro
i was hanging out yeah dude i was
hanging out
they were buying me beer i was like 16
years old 17 years old
where is the goggles situation dude
where i was going yeah with the goggles
that's a yo that's absolutely right oh
thank you i love you
yeah so i have a lot of i mean you know
and then there's it's kind of you know
it's interesting because i see like a
lot of these
like some of these people like really
just like
get by all right like i see this one guy
named stacks every now and then when i
was working at allen's boots and like he
would always walk up and just homeless
dude named stack yes really short guy
and he was just like you know how like
you know like a kind of sometimes yeah
like he literally will walk up to you
and just go hey
yeah and i'm just like
oh yeah he's like so good to see you man
and i'm like
all right
that's probably bro all the homeless
people yeah yeah
before you have sex dude
what about you check them out traveling
all over you ever come across like some
weird gutter punk vagabond [ __ ] or like
yeah i was at the home depot in
new york in brooklyn and some guy gave
me a rock it's like i want you to have
this
and now it's in my van it's wanking
around down there
so he was like here
he was in brooklyn shout outs home depot
oh you still be living there
hopefully not though
yeah
mine was uh
what was that oh i yelled help really
loud one time when this [ __ ]
crackhead lady wouldn't leave me alone i
was like you leave me alone i'm gonna
scream
and she was like oh yeah [ __ ]
i was like help
your [ __ ] face at the gas station
dude she just [ __ ] got scared and
walked away it worked
you out crazied her yeah
[Music]
yeah it worked hard
i had enough at that point
i uh
you know sometimes i'm out there with a
van and it gets stuck in the mud
and i need a i need a tow i need a good
old boy
a big old truck
come on down
yeah there it is yeah so just know
holler at hans y'all if y'all got some
[ __ ] trucks
for real and a lot of slimy reptiles out
there trying to slip into my butthole oh
man
dealing with hecklers is there any like
way you go to go about it i guess uh
authenticity uh just saying what you're
actually feeling and trying to match
your core with what's actually being
felt in the room and actually being said
uh is what is actually happening
and you know like uh
authenticity and
you know just dealing with the situation
as an organic moment like we're in a
room there's this person talking over
there there's this other person standing
by the door we've all been in this
situation so it's like just having those
that awareness and like using your
social strength and power to see how
much leverage you can get in the
physical world
and you know just playing with that a
little bit
that's a [ __ ]
stellar description
nobel prize [ __ ] yeah all right you guys
are musicians so you don't you guys ever
uh do that i mean it is i think
performing is that in general dude
as long as you [ __ ] commit to what
you do and do it like you know i mean
like you're good at it i mean you're
[ __ ] good at what you do and you're
making if you can stand up there for
long enough and not have people mad at
you yeah right right you can physically
do that yeah that is something or have
people mad at you
yeah
yeah i mean
so i have a question what was the worst
experience like
hands down with comedy that you had to
deal with
i don't know man
i don't know yeah like they all they're
all different in different ways you know
that's here what's a very memorable one
yeah like some of the worst ones are
where like i'm in front of a bunch of
like white people that are like super
like proper and they're like we're here
for a good time
sorry guys
[Laughter]
so there's a little bit of that a little
bit of that this a little bit of that uh
you know like or other times when it's
like you know like really sad
no one respects you because they're like
oh are they even there then but no i
mean i know you go to the grammy [ __ ]
like sometimes you gotta hit those opens
and they're pretty like unexpected
comedy that's why i've noticed like so
when i know this is like i'm still a
believer in that yeah but then it's that
unexpected [ __ ] when you just show up to
a mic
and people were there and now they
they're like maybe we'll see musicians
of being comedy and like it's hard bro
because everybody does what five minutes
a day yeah dude and everyone's in that
same level and you think that you're
better than the moment but you're not
and it teaches you like how to where
your strengths actually live yeah
yeah my uh
i think uh the acid really triggers my
uh jaw
so uh starts trip
drugs
you know
they exist
um you know sometimes i go on like drug
trips and like i go like in my
neighborhood and like walk around and i
make a fire and
and my and the property when i'm
supposed to make fires
um but i live in a van so it's like oh
you know everywhere is private property
so it's like i can't exist anywhere but
by the graces of the feudal lords that
occupy the capital
so i uh
make subservient gestures towards them
[Laughter]
i love it thank you thank you riley
uh but yeah
so yeah i'm just like he was assuming
the van i'm going camping so in that
moment i'll purely be camping i'll be
untethered i can go anywhere from there
so it'll be a good feeling to have
technically it's not
professionally it's a just an illusion
hans is there
is there anything you miss about old
society about like living in an
apartment or having you know
material items i guess
air conditioning
towels
um
what's the
showers
uh i try not to shower
thanks for this
we're in it right now my shower
situation
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i love it
who wants to drink
do you ever feel like you could get
canceled at any point in time yeah
are you trying to think about it
yeah i mean dude you gotta [ __ ] just
push on through baby i feel like
there'll be like a time where uh you
can't cancel anybody anymore or not that
you can't but like no one will give a
[ __ ] like to a point where like
everyone's been canceled you can just
keep going you know yeah that's where
hopefully we're at right now with us
yeah i mean yeah there's there's no need
for things to be getting softer so it's
like bro you know i mean there's so much
more [ __ ] to deal with than what people
will say satirically
to make a living off of stuff that makes
us happier it makes us laugh so why the
[ __ ] would you take that away you know
what i'm saying like why why would you
do that when there's
a hundred percent
yeah
but uh you
know what's your favorite animal
their animal would have to be
a goddamn
i want to be a t-rex
yo i want to be a pterodactyl oh yeah
there's all these guys
you got the bone structure i mean there
also wasn't a whole lot of a whole lot
of competition
competition in the sky so you can just
like my draws
[Laughter]
that's fun
that's real fun hans what kind of music
are you into man like or what did you
grow up listening to i grew up listening
to
a lot of
asians
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
yeah
kapop
oh
are you south korean or what what are
you
i'm west korean
[Laughter]
nice dude palm trees
[Music]
behind the scenes man what happens like
who do you like to kick away who's
really good hangs chill rogan's pretty
dang
uh
pretty good hangs both yeah i mean the
hang masters yeah
dude um
yeah like they occupy a different space
and they have to get good at their own
game which is
more complicated
and uh less ideal in some ways
but uh i mean
yeah
i'm a little
i know that's the lord it's so crazy
it's right under the future but yeah i
hope you realize that you
are well on your way there dude you
really are i'm not even just saying that
suck your dick
nah you're good bro you're amazing
you're great yeah you know i just gotta
keep doing everything the way i've been
doing it because no one will give me
50 000
a year to live just for nothing well
you're gonna not yet anyways get on that
tour trust me i feel like it's just a
matter of time and you're gonna be sick
you're gonna have all this affiliate
where do you get like uh your
inspiration from for comedy is it like
everyday [ __ ] in the streets or on your
travels yeah we're all part of life the
communism of it all
try to soak into that as much as
possible yeah it's true common humanism
and the beatles aspect
but uh i mean i think that's the end
result of all conversations so why not
just get there immediately
and like get good at that we couldn't
get good at anything we might as well
get good at the you know if conversation
has a use it's like
higher psychedelic talk so let's why not
just go
point in that direction yeah and then
everything else can get good at whatever
that they're doing vr can get a vr
it's true it really is true i mean it's
you tap into the [ __ ] war of your
brain
you really do i mean that's as easily
put that's as spelt out in kindergarten
as you can put but it's like you can you
you're deeper in your brain than you are
without it and it's like
it could be taken in a way that
supplemental
and i don't think it was bad for your
health you know maybe once you do it
moderately
yeah i mean i think it's something that
helps okay completely i mean i think it
taps into a core
that is beautiful and common and that's
why it's so illegalized
because they want us to
mistrust our core
it's our humanity yeah you're right do
you think uh
comedians like future comedians will be
eventually politicians the way they're
so good with talking with crowds and
being able to influence people
no
there's always gonna be like a divide
between like comedy and politics well
hopefully if there isn't that's a good
sign because that's a sign of a
meritocracy
uh but i think the uh existing spheres
of power are too strong and that's like
another part of my brain that i don't
want to think about yeah
like
i want to get good at the part where
like once we figure all that [ __ ] out
we're gonna be at eventually like why
stop in the middle and get good at like
whatever [ __ ] they're doing now why
segway when we could just get there do
you think chris just possess actual
power yeah yeah yeah i think it'd be
nice if they if they did i mean i feel
like
if you were
actually
on the right knights in the moonlight
yeah they they can actually
retain some of that energy from your
beliefs
i mean i guess you can tap into it any
way you want so have you ever sang a
girl while you're [ __ ] her from the
island of flies water
that's the [ __ ] that's the [ __ ] right
there
[Music]
that squad thursdays every thursday
come out
yeah well
i'm proud of you yeah
we all are i think a lot man it's really
cool to just like see like
how just like this i mean the whole
scene is taking off in the way that
you're shifting with it is really just
like and and the way not shifting with
it the way that you're like
over it yeah ruling over here
if you could nominate
a next comedian to come be on uh booze
and who's who would it be
there it is riley
we call upon you
bradley's fun dude can you fit in this
pool definitely all right
yeah he'll be great i can